rando pays vous propose cette semaine de
continuer la découverte du littoral du
sud sauvage avec une balade autour de la
marine de saint gilles il
mais bien
l'aïe
rendez vous sur le site de la mer casse
et à saint-philippe où l'on retrouve des
10 avril
notre accompagnateur du jour
ah si le sentier littoral au départ de
saint philippe et bien connu il est
aussi possible de découvrir ce goût de
cotes plus sauvage devant le village
ce qu'il fait
jean
une façon sympathique de rejoindre la
marine côté mer
le
malgré l'absence de sentiers les coulées
sont suffisamment large pour que la
progression soit facile sans trop
s'approcher de la falaise
ici encore malheureusement on n'évitera
pas les traditionnels incivilités de
personnes peu respectueuse de la nature
c'est tellement plus facile de laisser
traîner cvg
à
marcher sur les coûts les sites aussi
rencontré des membres de ce corps
différentes que peut prendre halal en se
refroidissant
on découvre ici aussi un super
plus spectaculaire
la traversée d'une belle forêt de vacoa
coïncide avec le passage devant la
maison forestière passé la forêt on peut
observer la marine de loin ils verront
belles lames la mairie bâtiment
une fois sur place on découpe les
bateaux entreposés à même le sol et
l'histoire du célèbre naufrage du warren
hastings cet endroit en fait est témoin
en fait d'une aventure assez incroyable
donc c'est une histoire que tous les
gens de saint philippe connaissent on a
ici en fait on est tout près du naufrage
du warren hastings le arena sting en
fait c'était un navire britannique qui a
navigué en fait au large
ici des décotes de saint philippe à la
fin du dix neuvième siècle donc c'est à
dire exactement en 1897
et malheureusement il a fini sa route
ici donc en fait il est parti du cap
c'est un navire à vapeur de 4000 tonnes
qui transportait quand même près de 1300
passagers et il devait se rendre à l'île
maurice donc à cause des mauvaises
conditions météo ce navire en fait a
échoué juste ici à quelques pas de la
marine de saint philippe à l'époque en
fait c'était quand même quelque chose
d'assez incroyable par rapport à la
sodagri de la solidarité en fait que les
gens ont apporté au soutien qu'ils ont
apporté aux naufragés donc sur les 1200
62 passagers pour être exact il ya eu on
a eu à déplorer en fait que deux morts
en fait ce sont deux personnes qui se
sont jetés à l'eau pour essayer de
regagner la côte et malheureusement qui
se sont noyés mais tous les autres
passagers ont pu être sauvés en fait
grâce à des cordages content du les gens
de la côte au navire
il est vrai que la mère semble toujours
déchaîné par ici et même bien aménagé le
passage pour la mise à l'eau des bateaux
n'est pas très rassurant encore quelques
passes ou les bacs aux as et on retrouve
la route du bord de mer qui matérialise
la fin de notre randonnée
ce que j'aime bien cette randonnée c'est
qu'on arrive à la marine de saint
philippe
mais par la cote donc on c'est une
manière différente de découvrir ce lieu
chargé d'histoire donc on est dans des
ambiances de bord de mer on est aussi de
sauvage donc on est vraiment au bord des
wagons sans vraiment les embruns on
les skieurs on est sous les va quoi
aussi c'est vrai qu'il ya sur ce
parcours en fait on n'est jamais
véritablement sur un sentier dont il
faut toujours longer près de la mer mais
on n'est jamais vraiment à la pique
on n'est jamais très haut au dessus de
l'eau et puis on a surtout des grandes
étendues de laves basaltiques qui permet
d'avancer de progresser sans être trop
près de la falaise
ce qui est sympa c'est que on est
vraiment à deux pas de la ville de saint
philippe
mais c'est une ville qui est pas
forcément tournés vers la mer donc il
n'ya pas de route qui passe près du
littoral
donc là on est ça permet de découvrir en
fait une autre facette de sa fille parce
que j'aime moi sur cette randonnée c'est
vrai que comme les fallait sans plus
basse on va rencontrer moins d'oiseaux
que les falaises qui va y avoir un petit
peu avant avant la commune de saint
pierre